second day of the workshop algorithms
loin policy just a few short reflections
from yesterday so many of us felt that
we had very important and interesting
discussions but time was really short so
we are very aware of that we certainly
didn't even have enough time as much as
we want to do develop our to fully
develop all of our discussions some
people cope with this by just typing
some thoughts and insights into the
chatbox so we saved that chat box was
saved and it will emailed to all of you
by the end of the workshop so please
feel free to do the same today if you
have something that we don't have enough
time for interaction please just type it
into the chat and then later will be
able to read down everything so the good
thing about it maybe is that it leaves
us with a taste of more with our eyes
toward the workshop that of course will
be held in person in Berkeley in April
ok another thing just for a very quick
follow-up to our workshop yesterday
there was a new New York time articles
that is highly related to our discussion
on Google and location and privacy
everything that we discussed yesterday
so it's in the chat now if you're
interested please take a look the plan
for today will start with a plenary
session with radiate a bidet and Martha
Minow about computation and social
justice then we'll have a short break a
after the break we'll have a simulation
about content moderation by AI it will
be run by an IVA elk and Quran and
Abigail and Shlomi code and we'll start
with a short intro and then we'll split
again into breakout rooms and there will
be some surprises and hidden stuff there
are so be prepared and then we'll
reconvene again for reports just like
yesterday so we'll need you very engaged
in this a stimulation session so please
keep your cameras and minds open for
this
then we'll have another short break and
we'll conclude with the great panel led
by Jennifer chase and of course how
knows we'll have another slider poll to
conclude okay so we'll start with Amnon
who will chair the first session thank
you very much Michelle my name is Amnon
right when I had the Haifa Center for
cyber law and policy and it is my honor
to invite professor editor a fellow at
Harvard Society of fellows and he's
gonna be joining UC Berkeley to talk
about the rules for computing computing
in social justice and then of course
professor Martha Minow
from Harvard Law School the former dean
to discuss without further ado professor
bill to the floor for his yours thank
you
okay so we're gonna first just do the
side sharing bit make sure that
everything's okay make sure we're all
set up okay so so you can all see this
right yeah okay very good and everyone
is how's everyone doing everyone's doing
okay ready we still have to be fair Rick
fungal okay see this is a wonder why
it's doing that
okay so let me do this again it's still
there yeah that's very weird isn't it
and let's see maybe we can just go like
these not forth green and then we don't
have the rectangle yeah then we just
yeah I think the rectangle is just there
I don't know why it's there but this
says you can still see the slides right
yes yes very good
all right let's just go with this if
it's too distracting we can try again
and how's everyone doing everyone's good
I can't actually see everyone so you
have to do audibly say you're good all
right thank you all for inviting me to
thank you to the organizers for inviting
me to this really incredible event a lot
of what I'll talk about today is
actually very deeply inspired by by a
lot of folks here in this room and a
seminar both people and
CS side of things and also folks on the
law policy and philosophy side so it was
really a surprise for me to be invited
but also a huge pleasure for me to be
sharing some of our work with you all
and so today I'm going to present on
some joint work with my colleagues
during my time at Cornell that you see
listed here but also some of what I'll
discuss is informed by my time as a
Corgan Iser of the mechanism design for
social good initiative and the black in
the eye initiative and so in a broader
sense this presentation is also joint
work with my with my partners and crimes
who least to these two initiatives so I
just wanna give a quick shout out so as
we all know we have deeply ingrained
issues of poverty and inequality here in
the US and also around the world so for
instance in Boston where I'm currently
based we know that over 1 in 5
individuals live in poverty so this is
just across the city one in five
individuals over 20 percent lives on
poverty and this number is actually
worse for some communities like senior
citizens immigrants black individuals
Latin X individuals individuals with
disabilities and so on and so forth and
our poverty alleviation programs are
really inadequate in the city and and
unfortunately Boston much like the rest
of the country is said to be living in a
sort of cultural denial of poverty and
of course all this is further
exacerbated by the ongoing crisis that
we're all enduring with the goal of
pandemic many families and especially
those on the margins of society have
lost their jobs they've lost their homes
and more importantly they've lost their
loved ones and a significant part of
this stems from long-standing issues
that we've had in this country and
around the world related to
discrimination and equality and
injustice that pervades all aspects of
our lives so this is not really just a
pandemic problem it's a very deeply
rooted problem so with this in the
background over the years many can
scientists have attempted to sort of
provide social support to provide
support in cases where maybe there's an
opportunity to predict outcomes or maybe
there's an opportunity to allocate
scarce societal resources all with the
hope of improving people's lives and in
this way algorithms have assisted in
decision making and incredibly
high-stakes scenarios like who gets
life-saving organ transplants and who do
we rent or sell houses to who do we hire
who's let out on bail and many and many
other incredibly high-stakes situations
but over the years we've also seen that
these attempts can actually really
backfire we now have endless examples
where algorithms have have actually
introduced perpetuated and worsened
existing inequalities we've seen this in
risk assessment in criminal justice
we've seen it in facial recognition
analysis we've seen it in bias and
search engines and really many many
other examples that were all intimately
familiar with and even in cases where
the sort of the actual stated goal of
what we're what we'd like to work on is
computing scholars is to support
vulnerable families critical scholars
argue that we can run into other
pressing issues like solution ISM which
indicates that there's a sort of
tendency to assume that computing will
solve our social problems and there's
also a sort of prevalent attitude of
tinkering where we sort of take the
contours of existing social and
political systems as given is fixed and
we try to kind of optimize around it
right so rather than tackling these
deep-rooted and justices head-on we're
sort of taking them as given and trying
to sort of like shuffle things around on
the margins so it's very natural to ask
at this point then desk computing have
any meaningful role to play in
addressing social problems given
everything that we've just seen is it
better is it are we just better off if
we just focus our attention and time on
other disciplines or activities or if we
think that computing does have a role to
play then how can we mitigate its risks
average its particular strengths so that
it can be a constructive ally for these
very long overdue social changes that we
would like to get to so this was
precisely the conversation that my
colleagues at Cornell and I had been
having over a period of several years
actually we spent quite a bit of time
reflecting on this very question we
talked through some of our favorite
examples from within machine learning
and algorithms and mechanism design and
we thought about what makes these
examples interesting or special and and
how we can how we can sort of maybe
leverage those or provide a framework
around those and in this process what we
concluded is that we think that
computing does have a valuable role to
play in addressing social problems and
the argument that we'll provide here our
goal is to sort of cut a path between
sort of solutionist perspective that
we've discussed but also a critical
perspective that might be that might end
up being quite limiting we want to
identify rules for competing that work
in harmony with other activities that
are also incredibly valuable and we want
to do so while keeping in mind that
previous critiques that we've mentioned
and a lot of this work is informed by
the values and design work that Helena
sebuah mentioned yesterday as well as a
lot of legal scholarship and other STS
scholarship that I'm not gonna mention
here but I do want to highlight that
this serves as an incredibly important
backdrop to to the framework that we
were able to provide in our in our paper
so specifically we identified four
different roles for computing so this is
competing as a diagnostic computing as a
formal Iser rebuttal and synecdoche
and I'm gonna go through some subset of
these and you know various various
levels of detail and the interest of
time but I do want to highlight that
this framer comes with the obvious
disclaimer that it's not meant to be
exhaustive and it's also a 90-day
mutually exclusive so so sort of keep
that in mind it's also an evolving
framework and so if you have further
thoughts please feel free to reach out
we're happy to chat but we do think that
despite these limitations it can provide
a sort of helpful structure
for thinking through some of our
competing contributions and why if and
why they've been able to sort of assist
in broader efforts for societal change
so what I'll do in the next few minutes
is I'll talk about a couple of these
roles in varying levels of detail and
I'll also save a little bit of time
towards the end to discuss broader
issues that might limit our ability to
see these roles through which I think
are incredibly important as well so
we'll start with the sort of very
popular role of computing computing as a
diagnostic this role is one that says
that while while computing might not be
able to solve problems on its own it can
actually play a very significant role in
measuring and precisely characterizing
the extent of these social problems and
we can especially do this in settings
where the problem it's manifesting
itself in technical system so you can
think about you know the facial analysis
and facial recognition example that I
gave that would be one such example so
if we think back to some of your
favorite works in this area you know the
first one that comes to mind is the 2013
work by the tiniest wienie at Harvard
showing that there's a sort of racial
bias and a delivery and in particular
there were there's a lot of
disproportionately high rates from ads
related to arrests actually to being
arrested that were more likely to appear
in response to searches where the first
names are commonly identified with
african-american individuals but there's
also many other examples from the past
past few years including the facial
analysis one also gender bias and word
embedding we have recent examples of
sort of bias and BIOS and racial biases
recognition and really many many other
examples is meant to be not a
representative sample I do want to kind
of dive into one example so I'll go I'll
go through one example from my own work
using health information bias in and how
they appear in search engines in this
work where we were able to do
as we took all searches from a fixed
period related to health searches
related to HIV and AIDS across the
African continent - all 54 nations in
Africa and we analyzed these searches to
sort of map out what are the varied
health information needs of individuals
and how much are these needs actually
being met and along the way we
identified many patterns like you know
which countries or demographic groups
are searching for things related to say
HIV and AIDS stigma or natural cures and
remedies for HIV and things like that
and we also show that there are these
significant discrepancies in the quality
of webpages
for searches related to natural cures
and remedies to show you just like a
very quick example if you say well right
now if you do it it's not gonna work but
back when I did this project if you
searched for dis currently cure HIV
either in pink which is what we were
using but really also in Google you
would see this sort of sample so the
first website that you see it's not just
like it's not just like the first
website it's actually highlighted as a
sort of answer and it's a website called
miracle of garlic calm and this was a
website that our our a school have you
know graduate level training and
medicine and public health went through
and weighted the content and rated it to
be very low they rated it to be not
relevant not accurate and not objective
in providing information related to
garlic and HIV but on the other hand if
you had searched for let's say
antiretroviral therapy HIV then the
webpage looks entirely the results page
looks entirely different the first
website that you see here is one that
was rated very highly by by folks who
rated our websites that I mentioned but
also the whole experience actually looks
very different you see on the right hand
side the Wikipedia page for management
of HIV and AIDS sort of highlighted you
see a lot of sort of suggested suggested
searches like okay if you're searching
for answer retroviral therapy for HIV
maybe also want to know like
you want to see the table of drug
interactions or sort of side effects and
things like that right so these two
webpages look very very different the
content that we're providing to users on
these search engines looks very
different depending on the search by the
topic with which their searches are
associated and we were able to quantify
these biases for our kind of very narrow
purpose and show that the natural cures
and remedies set of search for searches
often kind of were shown web pages that
were rated to be one point five out of
five so this was you know has serious
issues with relevance accuracy and
objectivity but on the other hand if
you're searching for stigma and
discrimination topics or breastfeeding
and pregnancy or antiretroviral drugs
then the rating goes up to four out of
five meaning that there weren't serious
issues with these along these criteria
that I mentioned to you and in this
process not only were we sort of able to
quantify what was going on here we also
were able to sort of think about the
mechanism via which this might be
happening so on the one hand you have
you know someone sitting in front of
their computer and searching for discard
leaky HIV or antiretroviral drug HIV and
of course that's going to play a role in
the content that they're gonna end up
seeing when the search engine returns
their results but there's kind of
intermediary steps right so you have
someone typing in their search query and
the web search your search engine will
do something right so in in the case of
Bing it does a sort of back-end
processing to sort of improve the
quality of your search so for instance
if you have typos and it might
automatically change these typos things
like that and then that search is then
mapped to to a web page or a set of web
pages and what we found was that
actually this sort of back-end
processing shows significant
discrepancies and so people searching
for natural cures and remedies their
searches were significantly less likely
to to be kind of treated by the sort of
back-end processing and that might be
affecting the quality of search is that
the quality of web pages that you end up
seeing
and the second issue and this was survey
from this was really surprising to me
actually the second issue is the
availability of web pages themselves so
if you restricted yourself to sort of
high authority web pages like the CDC
the NIH uho WTO UN Eve's and things like
that and you searched for you know all
the different types of searches related
to drugs or natural cures and remedies
you'll find that there's you know five
six seven times as many web pages
related to drugs versus natural cures
and remedies and sometimes this was
actually incredibly stark so there were
searches that were related to natural
cures and remedies where what we
restricted ourselves to one of these
high authority websites there was
literally no web pages that could be
shown and so what's happening is that
even if the web search the search engine
was doing an incredible job you were
still in the situation where there's not
high-quality content to show and
therefore and that void what was feeling
in was sort of low quality content like
blogs like Yahoo Answers like you know a
bunch of you know like the website that
we saw earlier and other things that are
providing lower quality health
information right so this was kind of
one example where we were able to we
weren't providing an answer we were just
looking at what are the issues out here
how bad are these issues right and we
were hoping that this could kind of
provide an opportunity to identify at
identify potential interventions going
forward and I'll pause here to say that
what I just mentioned is is precisely a
risk that we need to be thinking about
when we think about the role of
computing as a diagnostic we we sort of
we sort of mentioned here that we were
like kind of diagnosing the problem but
it's incredibly tempting to treat the
diagnosis itself as the goal to think
that okay if I just specify the problem
well enough then like the solution will
kind of naturally fall out of that or
something but as ruja benjamin puts it
data ensure it does not speak for
themselves
and they don't always change hearts and
minds or policy right so was she saying
and
it's absolutely true is that there are
many settings in many domains where we
actually know the extent of problem so
we know that mass incarceration in the
u.s. is a significant problem we know
that chronic homelessness is a huge
problem and and we're very well aware to
the extent of these problems and yet we
don't really have either enough
consensus or political will or whatever
it is to actually address these issues
these are long-standing issues they've
been a problem for a very long time
right and so it's very important to make
sure that in in sort of using this role
of computing as a diagnostic to not
confuse that with with treatment or
interventions we're just diagnosing the
problem and there's other risks as well
so one that you might have already
thought of is good hearts law which says
that if you have a sort of metric that
is being used to characterize the
performance of the system then now
you've sort of created an incentive for
individuals and organisations to maybe
change their behavior and maybe change
their behavior in ways that you don't
necessarily want and sort of corrupt the
meaning of this metric right so the
metric itself can become the target so
it's important to keep these two risks
and actually really many other risks in
mind and but even setting these aside we
still think that computing can play a
significant role in diagnosing social
problems especially as they manifest in
technical systems and other rules of
computing can actually acts directly and
how social problems are understood so we
know that algorithmic problems require
that we are very explicit about our
input about our constraints about our
goals right and a lot of policy is kind
of different a lot of policy aims tend
to be seated and sort of vague and
ambiguous terms so you might you know
see more sentences like you know the
social worker wants to act in the best
interest of the child or the employer
wants to hire the most qualified
applicant and things like that
and yet these these phrases best
interests of the child or the most
qualified applicant or help the most
number of people are actually very very
vague right and this vagueness
be a very important tool it can be it
can provide flexibility and sort of
leave you wide latitude for
interpretation that might be more
appropriate for your a specific setting
and it might also help with consensus
building because if you are very
specific than maybe I'm actually getting
a lot of people on board might be harder
but in reality what happens is that the
task of you know taking these phrases
like best interest of the child or most
qualified applicants and sort of
concretely writing it down in a way that
that has to get implemented ends up
being sort of delegated to people or
institutions that either have less
scrutiny right they might be less open
to scrutiny or maybe they're just simply
not well equipped to actually translate
these sort of policy aims and to
concrete objectives right so there's
sort of disconnect here that we ought to
address and at the same time we know
that the nature of computing is to be
very concrete and unambiguous and of
course there are many downsides to that
but also there's some upsides it can
help us as a sort of opportunity
opportunity for conversation it can
serve as a sort of natural intermediary
intermediate target for advocacy so what
does that look like in practice we can
take for instance a homelessness and
sort of housing instability in the US
which is a huge issue and we have many
many different types of housing
assistance programs in the US but many
of them are sort of working in a setting
where they have scarce resources and
they have to sort of allocate them to
families in order to mitigate this
housing instability issue that I
mentioned and this kind of optimization
problem that they have to solve forces
that's to be very specific about our
objective function what are the thing
that what is the thing that we're trying
to optimize for right and the setting we
say ok we want to help the most number
of families but we have to actually be
more concrete about that so you might
think okay there's like two sort of
objective functions that are quite
popular that we might use so one will
say I want to minimize the number of
families that experience eviction sort
of an expectation right so this is all
your working sort of an expectation and
another objective might say
I'm gonna identify the most vulnerable
family make sure that they're as
well-off as possible so it's sort of
like you were kind of lifting the floor
in a sense right and these are very
popular objective functions they seemed
perfectly reasonable
they're definitely widely used they've
seen defensible right but what we found
in our work with John Kleinberg about
Weinberg was on this call too is that
actually in a very stylized setting even
a very stylized setting where we can
solve this optimization problem
completely right under both of these
sort of different objectives we we find
that the consequence of picking one
objective versus making another
objective can be very dire and in
particular if you sort of have like a
restricted budget for how many people
you can assist and you optimally solve
for one objective versus another you
could actually be in a situation where
it tells you that the people the set of
people that you're targeting are
entirely disjoint right and that's you
know incredibly undesirable because
these are two objective functions that
we think are reasonable and yet they're
telling us to do the exact opposite
thing so in a way what this kind of
optimization problem that we formulated
did is to formalize and sort of maybe
bring some analytic clarity into our
goals and objectives and what's actually
sort of feasible in this setting right
so we're sort of thinking about like the
scope of what's possible given the fixed
budget that we have and in a way what
that's when it's been able to do is to
sort of provide further evidence that
perhaps what we're missing here is not
just that we don't know how to formulate
the problem very well or maybe we're
just like not efficiently allocating
things enough well maybe what we're
missing here is just having more
resources right so Robert Mendota who's
a sociologist argues that sort of many
of our pressing social problems cannot
be solved by sort of better allocating
existing sets of outcomes and we
actually need to have new outcomes and
so this formalizing process can actually
sort of provide further evidence for
that and actually serve as further
evidence for the type of advocacy that
we may like to do so in the u.s. we know
that
you know one in four renters are
severely severely rent burdened and this
number has actually doubled since the
1960s we're sort of and then we're sort
of actually in the worst housing crisis
in decades and this is even setting
aside the pandemic but with the pandemic
we are now sort of at the cost of like
massive fictions and significant housing
instability that might take us years or
decades to sort of undo right and so and
so this is sort of an opportunity for us
to take the evidence that we have from
the formula from the formulism side as
well and add to the sort of advocacy
that needs to be that needs to be
happening to expand the funding that's
available rather than just sort of
shuffling the existing funding around
and hoping that that solves our problem
and in this way this example that I'm
giving you actually serves both as sort
of like a formalize there and what we
call a rebuttal
so the rebuttal example is saying that
computing scholars are very
well-equipped to to say what algorithmic
optimization in the AI systems cannot do
right it can clarify the sort of limits
of the technical interventions and say
look if you are trying to achieve this
and this is the set of constraints that
you have then it's it's actually like
not possible for you to achieve what you
would like to achieve and we've seen
this in a number of ways we saw one with
organization problem earlier it's very
popular and electronic voting and
encryption we're all very familiar with
the sort of the many and possibility
results that we have in the fairness and
the algorithmic fairness literature and
its third example that I really really
like is by sort of a group of computing
scholars that pushed back on a proposal
by the immigrations Customs Enforcement
like two years ago there was a proposal
by ice to use an algorithm and data from
like social media and what-have-you to
assess whether a visa applicant would
become a positive contributing member of
society that was sort of what they were
aiming to do as part of the extreme
vetting program and when this proposal
was announced it rightfully got a lot of
pushback from many people and computing
scar
I stepped in here to say look there's
literally no computational method that
can provide a reliable or objective
assessment of these streets that you're
looking for right so there was sort of a
set of documents that were that were
that were released I think several of
the folks on this call were actually
part of it and be doing it right and so
this is sort of an example where as
computing scholars we know what is
impossible and we can say this is
actually impossible so you should just
look elsewhere and in this particular
example we know that the program ended
up getting abandoned so that was sort of
that was sort of good news
so we returned to where we started we
kind of outlined these different roles
that computing can play I didn't go
through all of them and not enough
detail but there but they are here I
wanted to kind of give you a flavor of
them I would highly recommend reading
the paper the company paper if you're
interested but I do want to highlight
one sort of difference which is that
here I'm talking about sort of computing
for social change but my talk title was
on computing for social justice right so
how do we get from sort of social change
which can be like arbitrary to social
justice right which is maybe what we're
really talking about and what I really
like to do now is to talk about a few
issues that traditionally are not
considered part of academic research and
so are not really sufficiently talked
about I think but I think we really
ought to invest energy and time and
these and these and these issues if
we're able to make progress as a
community the first of these is that we
have to take responsibility that about
how our research is being understood or
used right so this the community as a
whole has a responsibility to sort of
say okay here's the research that we've
done and it might be the case that you
know it's actually like good work and it
could be relevant to policy and yet we
don't necessarily do this sort of the
translation work right it could be the
case that you know you have a set of
results and ask to actually get
implemented but there's a sort of
unfortunate I think not very justified
dichotomy between engineers and science
it was sort of like well you know I did
the science and the engineer is going to
implement it and that's not really my
problem right but actually think that
that is part of our that is part of our
job to make sure that there's not
significant sort of loss in translation
when when we go from like the science to
the actual implementation and worst of
all you know this is sort of like
clockwork we see every six months some
tool that ends up being built that is I
clearly just not a very good tool it's
clearly gonna be misused or it's clearly
just gonna be used to harm to harm
communities and we and we just keep
hearing this kind of we keep seeing this
sort of hiding behind the covers of well
just like I'm just doing the science
right so you know I was just doing the
science why is that part of my
responsibility and I think we have to
really recognize and claim this
translation aspect of our work as really
as part of our mandate and really take
that to heart if we are going to make
progress and really contribute to issues
of social justice the second thing I
want to bring up is is this sort of
multidisciplinary collaborations even in
situations where we actually do have
collaborations with domain experts or
you know scholars from other fields we
sometimes have what Jennifer called
yesterday sort of drive-by
interdisciplinary collaborations which I
really appreciate right these sort of
collaborations that are not really built
on equal partnership and they're not
built on trust it's a sort of very
transient an opportunistic thing and
many times actually it can be set up in
such a way that is very extractive of
communities and some settings that can
be actually very cool one'll istic right
and so we really have to be aware of
this and we have to we have to recognize
that building these partnerships and
building trust actually takes a really
really long time
and that time is going to come out of
somewhere right and so really to try to
value that in our communities and I in
the interest of time I'm not going to be
able to get into this but this is
something that through the empty
forestry community we've worked on over
the past I guess not four years and we
have some insights here we have some
models that we that we really like I
won't have time to share them now but I
be very happy to chat with you about
them in the future and also hear what
you what you think if you have other
models that you really like as well and
the last point that I want to make and
in many ways I think this is the most
important one at least for me is that
it's the issue of representation
representation and computing really
really matters if we want to make sure
that the benefits of our contributions
are equally contribute are equally
distributed across society that certain
communities are not being actively
harmed by our contributions then we
really have a responsibility to ensure
that our research communities represent
society and that we have sort of a more
inclusive research community and I know
we've talked about I mean I just kind of
came on the scene not that long ago I
know people have talked about this for
decades and decades and it's kind of
disheartening to see actually how little
progress we've made and how much that's
impacting our research developments and
if you look at for instance the CRA
certainly from 2019 it has this table
has the number of PhD graduates from
computer science from 2019 and you'll
find there that there was only 13 people
that graduated with a CS PhD who are
black or african-american right so I
graduated 2019 so I was one of the 13
people and this is you know well over
2000 people graduated with CS PhDs and
only 13 of them are black and it's even
worse for some communities so for
American Indian or Alaska native it was
only 2 people that year that graduated
and this number is not an outlier it's
consistently this bad right it's
consistently this bad every year and
like you know things are like a little
bit changing but not really I think
there's a lot of fluctuation some years
are really terrible and then other year
something like there's a slight bump and
I think we kind of get very complacent
and this reflects in who ends up being
kind of researchers at the faculty level
as well so if you look at the over 5,000
faculty that are sort of represented in
this table so this is looking at full
associated assistant professors in
computer science you'll find that 23 23
black folks are full professors
for our associates and 38 our assistant
right so we have only 85 black and
African and black and african-american
individuals who are full associate or
assistant professors and computer
science departments and again this
number is much worse if you're looking
at American and Indian or Alaska Native
individuals where we only have 10 right
so this is 10 out of well over 5,000 and
I think it would be really disingenuous
this you that that this does not impact
our research the types of questions that
we ask what we prioritize and what we
think is is a valued contribution in
computer science so so we really have a
very long way to go and I'll give a very
quick shout out to my colleague in
blackening I Devon killary whose I guess
going to be my colleague of Berkley also
who wrote this article called combating
anti black racism tag blackness and the
AI community and it really is an
incredibly helpful article I highly
recommend that you read it if this is
something that you think about and and
I'll just give a quick shout out to the
black in the eye community which is an
initiative that I co-founded with Tanika
who and have been organizing over the
past three years I think that
organizations like black knee I can make
a significant difference but I think at
the same time you should be honest about
you know who the burden of increasing
representation and inclusion tends to
fall on and whether we end up valuing
that or taking it into account when
we're making decisions around hiring or
promotions which is you know how we pay
the bills right so on that note I will
conclude and I'd be happy to take any
questions but I guess Martha Martha it's
gonna take over right right thank you
very much redic Martha the floor is now
yours do you want to share slides I
think Mars I think you muted oh now
you're not I would like to share one
slide can you see it not yet
yes no now we can see it yeah networks
good well I am so grateful for this
paper uh it is invigorating and
encouraging and empowering I couldn't
help but think about Audrey Lords famous
quotation when I was reading the paper
which is something that as a lawyer I
frankly have to think about a lot
she said the Masters tools will never
dismantle the Masters house they may
allow us temporarily to beat him at his
own game but they will never enable us
to bring about genuine change and this
is an issue particularly in American law
where the tools of law were completely
involved in constructing injustice as
well as declaring that all human beings
have rights the interesting thing about
that insight when it comes to computing
is the computing is relatively recent
it's didn't build the Masters house and
so it's still open to the question how
will it be used and that's where I find
this paper so empowering and so
encouraging I think that the analysis
proceeds powerfully by broadening the
frame of the usual analysis rather than
focus on the problem and solution we are
invited to a larger field of the
construction of knowledge and embedded
in a plane of social and economic
structures and inequalities and I just
think that's enriching and deepening and
and reminder that this kind of work can
be done the paper though also draws on
the qualities of computational analysis
that I have learned to admire greatly
precision we lawyers are so fuzzy and so
very often and we justify our vagueness
but I have learned with colleagues like
Shafi that there's a reason for
formalism and it also has the quality
that's really made clear in the four
recommended roles of making clear what
is unclear and making available for
contest and debate matters that have
been obscured and I think those are
incredibly valuable and important
features and one more feature that I
recognize particularly from crypto work
is the structure of the paper which is
organized around promises and risks
promises and risks and I see a smile so
yes and I recognize this because we do
this in law too and it's a you know
adversarial and I think things get
better when you do it that way
it's very striking that more in the
paper than in the presentation it ends
with the discussion about poverty labor
and capitalism and I think it's just
crucial to locate those as features of
the larger context who's doing the labor
who is in poverty who is the client for
the work and I think that's implicit in
the paper but I wonder if it could be
made even sharper who's commissioning
the work and for what purposes what's
not on the agenda who's responsible
these closing comments that were so
excellent about the ethics of expertise
and as the chat indicated there's no
reason to have to sacrifice rigor and
progress while paying attention to
consequences but to not ask about the
consequences is an ethical problem there
is one observation the paper that I
guess I want to use as the basis for the
remainder of my remarks which is there
is a risk once of identifying the
criticism of throwing the baby out with
the bathwater because even the imperfect
can be helpful and so I would invite us
all to think about the potential uses of
tech tools
for social justice for redistributing
and making equal the distribution of
wealth opportunity respect political and
economic resources and so I'm gonna
offer a few with no pride but just as
ideas the first comes from my work in
the legal services world we're trying to
find ways to get legal representation
for poor people in this country is such
an uphill battle some eighty to ninety
percent of family law matters in this
country have both parties with no lawyer
in the landlord-tenant context that is
now a tsunami that we're hitting it is
the tenants who have no lawyer the
landlord's have lawyers and I work hard
on trying to get lawyers funded and and
so forth but the fact is we do not have
a basis in our current economic system
to pay for the lawyers that are needed
for all the people who don't have them
and so this is really the origin of my
interest in in tech because the tech
tools that can lower the barriers to
access to justice we're just on the cusp
of a revolution
it can make rights enforcement
frictionless rather than having to go to
court and wait and go through
bureaucracy
you know representing veterans who are
entitled to benefits they should be able
to have the same seamless access that we
have when we go to Amazon to be able to
claim their benefits but they don't the
problem is you start to realize this is
not by accident that we have a system
that makes it very hard for people to be
able to enforce their rights and be able
to and make their claims and that's part
of the contest we could expose well if
you don't want to make it easy then why
is that
and so that's an example another is to
turn the tools back on the powerful this
is of course best illuminated right now
with
body cameras on the police but there are
similar efforts now that I'm very
excited about to use the same risk
assessment tools that are so problematic
in criminal justice to turn the back on
the judges and to assess their behavior
and to see how their sentences differ
depending if it's before lunch or after
lunch or the order in which the cases
are put uh it's it is quite disruptive
and exposing a lot of the inequalities
that operate behind the veil of the
justice system deploy tools and new ways
for example journalists could use zero
knowledge proof to be able to verify
that they have access to information
without revealing their sources and
other kinds of security tools that could
open up spaces for communication away
from surveillance what about the
supportive platforms for innovative uses
of knowledge for people who haven't had
the access to data analysis I'm thinking
here about some interesting efforts to
help people who are homeless actually
have access to data that they can use in
their own advocacy and just one small
comment on collaboration in this context
from years of work in with local
communities I've learned that actually
equal collaboration may be the wrong way
to think about it at least as a lawyer
we really have to think of ourselves in
service of others who are defining the
goals and the the risk of our own
definition of here's what we should be
doing is so great that I think that kind
of humility would be helpful in the
context of computing as well so in
contrast with Audrey Lorde maybe maybe
these new tools will help us diagnose
expose choices widen the field of view
deepen critique deepen contest deepen
collaborations and redistribute power
thank you for the paper
wonderful Martha thank you very much for
those inspiring words and the floor is
now open
for the next 13 minutes or so for
questions and comments please be kind to
perhaps raise your hands I will see you
in the participant list and then we can
perhaps of silicate some conversation
the floor is open so we also have some
chats we could we could go with those
yes please please you can also of course
address the comments in the chats yes
please go ahead so me I'll just go with
the last one that that was just sent by
Y Adam Smith although Adam do you wanna
do you wanna Fraser do you want to say
your question sure it was more of a I
guess a comment a question reading the
article I really liked the article in
the way you sort of decompose these
different roles I think when you come to
computing as formalization I guess I had
a - two comments one both both
reinforcing I think the things you
already say one is that the sort of
point that I think is often raised by
people who come from a commuting
perspective or just a more technical
background is that you know anytime you
have a system of rules what doesn't
really matter whether or not it's being
applied by computers you know that
constitutes a formalization of some
concept right and and basically you know
we like to think that these rules are
formulated with enough flexibility for
humans to exercise judgment but if
you've got like you know many thousands
of people making decisions separately
like you know you like I don't within a
bank you've got lots of these lend you
know lending officers making individual
decisions they're being given such
precise guidance in many cases that you
know that system is a formalization of
some concept whether or not you
comfortable you know viewing it as such
right so one of the nice things about
computing and you know the the
computational perspective is it makes
that formalization explicit right and
that and that reinforces your point that
it allows for interrogation the other
point I wanted to make is sort of maybe
a different type of formalization from
the ones you guys focus on in the in the
paragraph it's not it I guess it's not
only that computing allows us to
formalize things by making say explicit
objective you know listing explicit
objective functions of the kind you
might have with you know machine
learning the training algorithm but also
if you look at say like defining
security or defining concepts like
privacy that's a type of formalization
effort that is kind of qualitatively
different but also has a lot of the
features you mentioned that it provides
you know gives you some clarity it
allows for interrogation but it can
easily it may be hard you had this nice
phrase in your paper or the it some you
know it may fail to incorporate some
values or may may not be explicit about
the values its encoding right so there's
there's that danger still but it's a
kind of equality this seems like
defining privacy or security like having
encryption and things like that is
qualitatively different from say
formalizing the objective function you
use in an optimization process so I'm
not sorry yeah I think you know I
appreciate these these comments I wanted
to say um like I appreciate what you're
saying about sometimes we talk about
algorithmic decision making but actually
a lot of the arguments that we make
could apply for you know any you know
human decision-making as well right and
and so like you know if you're looking
at for instance some of these
impossibility results that we're all
familiar with now um they sort of
actually applied to like a human as well
it's not just an algorithm right if you
have these like set of criteria and they
can't be simultaneously satisfied
they're just a human is not going to be
able to do that and I
this is like sort of where the the
disconnect that I saw in terms of like
actually seeing our results through
right because what has happened is that
there was like an opportunity for us to
take those impossibility results and say
listen these things that we think are
reasonable can't be simultaneously
satisfied except for like very kind of
corner cases and and we still have these
like cash bail systems right so maybe we
should just consider just abandoning
that altogether because it's not really
it's not really a reasonable way to kind
of like implement this right and we
didn't necessarily do that I think
there's a sort of like a gap between
like the advocacy work that we could be
doing with our with our research that we
don't necessarily do and so what ended
up happening as a result is that sort of
the the companies that actually set
these like um these algorithms use those
results and said look you know these
things are not simultaneously
satisfiable therefore you know my
algorithm can be like arbitrary me bad
and I'll just kind of use this as a sort
of scapegoat right and so like that's
what I was saying when I was talking
about just like we actually happen to
take responsibility for how our results
end up getting to like you know
understood and and kind of wielded in
practice because it can actually kind of
go both ways yes Martha I'd like to pick
up on that and say that another theme in
the paper that's really we're talking
about is once there's a critique the
tendency very often is okay I'll fix
that rather than again to widen the view
and I just think that's a really really
great admonition and it's understandable
I had a seminar in graduate school on
social innovation and I will never
forget the first day everyone went
around the room and said that what they
tried to do it having worked and the
professor said we're gonna study here
why social innovations always fail which
was incredibly depressing but what what
I learned was that very very often
people who encounter and demonstrations
of failure just do more of what they
were doing already and the challenge is
how to not keep doing what you were
doing already
but I also want to pick up on the chat
there's several comments about the issue
of fuzzy fuzziness and ambiguity which I
agree is a feature not above in the law
and I'm always intrigued to learn about
tools in formalization and in computing
that can incorporate fuzziness or use it
but I do want to just take an example
that's relevant to our discussion take
privacy in the law
what does privacy mean well privacy
means at least six very different
concepts
it means perhaps seclusion it means
anonymity
it means control over who has
information
it means bodily integrity it means self
determination with autonomy and it means
protection against the negative
consequences of information about
yourself to use the same word to mean
those different things is obscuring and
it certainly makes it very difficult to
construct a policy if you can't even
specify which one you're after so that's
the kind of ambiguity that I do think
that computational approaches really
challenges and sometimes economic
analysis does as well okay thank you
of course the question of the
relationship between the type of
languages we use with a math and human
language in and of itself generates
different kinds of fuzziness and of
course the relationship between rules
and standards which is obvious obviously
known to lawyers is also part of it
formalizing standards is a bit tricky
can I just offer one thing I learnt
about the application of some of the
sentencing and and risk recidivism risk
algorithms in the difference between the
way they're applied in federal court and
state court state and local court
settings
and and I'm coming back I think to the
reddit to the to the the question that I
think you raised about the broader
context in which these tools are used
and one of the things I've learned about
the federal sentencing process is that
there are analysts who use a variety of
predictive algorithms but the judges who
make the ultimate decisions about
sentencing never see the scores and it's
an interesting it's it's a it's a it's
an interesting way to I think recognize
perhaps the limitation of tools and
particularly and maybe even the
limitation of formalization because you
always formalize according to some
perhaps restrictive limited set of
metrics and and well I I'm a very Pro
transparency person and I spend a huge
amount of time on trying to understand
how to make systems more transparent so
I agree with the benefit of all that but
perhaps we don't understand enough about
the limits of the uses of these kinds of
you know metrics based formalization
okay we have three hands raised and we
have three minutes to go
so perhaps what we can do is if people
can restrict themselves to one one
minute a question then we can hang on
Hank during the recess we have we're
going to go for a break in two or three
minutes and then people can still remain
and discuss this is a fascinating
subject so you viola please so this is a
question to radiate so you talk a lot
and I think there is a lot of moving the
computing process but I come from
behavioral economics and law proach
where we studied the biases of people
and sometimes I feel with all the
criticism about computers
people might think we need to go back to
to human decision-making again we know
this is really flawed so I think to some
extent the reason is the expectation of
computers being great and if they're not
great maybe we need to bring people back
but we need to remember
we were with people decision I I thank
you and I will have to set aside like an
hour to go through this I maybe will do
it over the break or something I I have
I have very strong opinions okay
the floor is yours um two quick points
when I wanted to just emphasize that
we're having conversations again about
this issue of kind of conceptual
fidelity what do we mean when we talk
about what we think is a simple term
privacy fairness etc and that we need I
believe what are called boundary objects
things that help us reason collectively
across disciplinary boundaries and I
want to point out to that I've helped
develop one is an analytic for privacy
and the other is basically an analytic
for fairness that don't tell you what
the concepts are but actually help you
collectively reason about what
definition you're seeking to build
towards and I think those sorts of
boundary objects are really important in
this space and the second is work that
Helen and I have been doing on this
conceptual model for thinking about
handing off functions between humans and
machines and you know it's never as
simple as it seems and formalizations in
different technical configurations or
different socio technical configurations
are going to have different impact on
the ground and different impact on
different values that we care about and
so we can't talk and kind of broad
generalities about what the outputs of
either which is better which is worse
because it's never that simple
thank you degree
Helen one last comment and then we and
then we're going to take a break well it
was gonna be a question and I'll make it
into comment which is
sorry it's about the impossibility and
the ice example where it was terrific
and I suppose I'm I'm interested in how
when you have formalisms that are
impossible to embed in a system whether
there's a comparison to make between
many issues that say legal scholars and
courts are confronting when you have
multiple values that are conflicting
with one another and then how law and
philosophy political philosophy resolve
those conflicts and how computer systems
look at these impossible constraints and
you know resolve those I find it
fascinating I'd love to think about it
more thank you very much all we are men
one minute behind our schedule it's a
tight schedule so we're gonna reconvene
in 14 minutes and quarter to I'm gonna
stay here if anyone wants to discuss it
I'm gonna stay there as well